welcome to this video ever call Leah
corner yeah I plead this guy before five
out of six yeah but I'm vulnerable today
yeah I lost against Maradona a game
where I was winning all the time and
spoiled it completely and he never beat
me before with the cheese explain
account so i really have to make sure
that i'm not starting a losing streak
against this guy so we have a classical
classical um nims over here with quincy
to that like has played in a slightly
offbeat fashion but not badly this is
some this is playable okay i can go to
over there briefly thinking g5 bishop g3
g4 with a check on g2 would start
problem
you know interesting moment will be if
he takes on c3 no it's not okay yeah is
this really a good spot for five I can
take care also okay I play I have ideas
like Bishop f5 which is a problem here
in this position and tending Bishop
takes d7 and he really has no great way
to recapture also intending long castles
interesting I could have kept long maybe
anyway but maybe se for then ok I think
Bishop f5 is this correct this is a good
move I wonder if he has to play g5 maybe
I staking their ok
yeah I can't have to keep shy yes
yeah stuff with long castles this
assistance is going to be ugly black has
to put up really Oh a really passive
defense is what I was trying to the same
would really love to Castle long him but
I don't i'm not able to hmm
look the 127 m it looks terrible but I
don't see em I direct a direct win or
something yeah maybe I should still do
it it I was i'm looking for direct wins
but i don't i don't see him a 3 is
something that I'm not sure if I should
play it because 95 is such a strong
threat he probably has to it has to
check anyway and he did ok so i have two
bishops here and a good central control
queen on c3 worked to look T one simple
continuations very hard for him to get
his some get his pieces coordinated 94
is this a move no not working ok I can
take it and take you five at the end hmm
ok
I wonder if I can play a 4 here is Queen
really if he takes takes castles rookie
one is winning the Queen just like that
the Queen has no squares I can play
Bishop I can play 96 ok hmm look d5 you
can take it and text my queen ok I'm
still playing that I really think that
this is right take stakes castles rookie
196 Bishop somewhere intending f5 or
queen d3 our asses like everything's on
this position it should be good it
really should be and I don't think I
should play a slow move I really should
play aggressively he still cannot play
94 there should be four 94 Queen takes
d5 if everything else fails I can always
do that winning a porn with the winning
position on top I wonder if she takes
that the recapture his best he takes a
form and then rookie one
Bishop c2 intending fi that's very
strong black has a big problem now yeah
I have to take an hour rocky one as the
threat Castle through kevy 196 Bishop
see to back intending f5 and he cannot
he does not have any squares no Bishop
c2 I thought near five and I don't see I
don't see what he does against it just
just doing a five the Queen has no
square to go to g6 I mean Honor I'm on
f6 so it's a complete domination of the
bishop Pam now no move yeah f5 I guess
or is that who is there some trick and
let's let's play it look to one Bishop
t1
they would have taken on dat s queen
diego and black resides yeah i think i
think this was good yeah f for that
looked it looked looked looked strong
let's see what the comp is giving F for
winning yep okay that's good Bishop d3
is also strong and but f-for is a strong
reply the comp gives g6 as the best
defense g6 Bishop g2 and g5 Wow but
still one point for our something for
white and here I'm completely winning
him here here Bishop see to 55 year okay
so i think i did i did a decent job here
i think ii five is mistimed really
because it sets difficult problems not
for black this Bishop d7 idea is really
i named takes pawn takes here rook g1 is
given by the computers even stronger
yeah possible possible but i think i
should keep a big edge here as well it
takes yeah and now we actually come to
the situation where you went a5 yeah a
virus is definitely too slow but it's
not it's not much fun to play this
position the comp wants to do this and
now castling accepting this before most
g5 feedback back and this by this white
is in fantastic shape here to bishops
and he's got the the Swiss cheese
formation yeah II five g5 well that's
not looking good of course this is
tougher than than the actual game but
still not a good position alright thanks
for watching